seeing is how people kind of like the
last crossover game Phoenix tried it
again this time they trim the fat of the
other two peter parker's and just decide
to stick with the original one plus
cyberpunk Spidey
spider-man edge of time came out only
one year after the previous installment
so as you can expect not a lot has
changed it's one of those games that's a
sequel but feels like an enormous DLC
because it uses the same assets gameplay
and some character models this game is
too shattered Dimensions as fallout new
vegas is to fallout 3 that's not to say
it's a bad game but it was definitely
pieced together with scraps of whatever
they were doing the year poor what
separates her from the previous one is
that it has a much more focused story
and the characters are spot-on to the
comics the plot involves time travel but
it does it in a lot of fun ways this
game is co-written by Peter David a
favorite author of mine who does sci-fi
novels and created spider-man 2099 I'm
happy that this games writing has a much
better understanding of the character of
Miguel O'Hara who I say still one of the
best comic things to come out of the 90s
both Spider Men are played by my
favorite voice actors from both the
shows I watched as a kid now the thing
about this game is that it plays and
looks almost exactly like the last one
normally I would just say a few things
about it and skip right on to the next
one but this one is the last great story
we've had in this entire series and I
want to highlight it for that reason
because it really stands out among the
rest so kids get your thinking caps on
we're gonna learn about time travel and
quantum physics according to comic book
logic I hope no one has a gun that'll
send my soul back in time that's a
legitimate concern we begin our story
with the half Irish half Mexican
spider-man of the future narrating about
how much he hates his job and his new
boss soy swings over to break into the
place to continue pushing his anti
corporate agenda
hey man the corporation's ruining
America with their business and stocks
and [ __ ] i'ma go use my genetically
augmented superpowers direct the place
and threaten my co-workers so it crawls
around in some vents and a cool opening
sequence and finds out that his boss
Walker Sloan is travelling back in time
to start their evil company alchemax way
earlier and take over the world
this changes the present Marvel Universe
and turns 2099 into an evil sprawling
cyberpunk metropolis damn corporations
Miguel is the only person who remembers
the other timeline when he gets stuck
between
time zones and learns that Peter Parker
is going to get murdered
thus he begins his quest to restore the
timeline and save his namesake get me
pictures of spider-man yeah I missed
that guy
Peter Peter Parker who's that who's
talking Miguel O'Hara the spider-man
from 2099
are the other Me's in my head - no it's
just me and you old timer so I really
like this game but the first gripe I
have is that the opening has so little
time to develop some stuff we get like
one or two lines of dialogue to quickly
recap what the hell is going on and then
we get back to doing crazy [ __ ] like
stopping time and fighting clones
Miguel uses a sample of Peters DNA to
create a I threw together a chronal ink
program using a sample of your DNA I
yeah what he said
get I'm thinking whoa whoa whoa slow
down there space cowboy could you
explain that better how does having a
blood sample allow you to create a radio
signal to someone else's brain that
works through time and space it
certainly isn't something you just threw
together in a few minutes it's allowing
you to have some questions what is
taking how does that work we ship is
where dinner on when did this notice
what a loo hey wait for slow on 29 a
increment ago hey why don't we try to
send him some time to understand ascend
wait come on
mind telling the audience how and when
you did that Miguel Sloane's building
another gateway on the 66th floor so he
can finally travel back and forth how
he's too busy dropping supervillains off
highways he's now listening well I do
love the way they transition from one
character to the other and showing each
of them in the corner gives you a
feeling that both are dealing with their
own problems even when you aren't
controlling them they got rid of those
damn spider tokens and replace them with
these little orbs and I can't help but
pick up every single one I see even
though it I don't even buy the character
upgrades it's like they designed this to
toy with my OCD so you want to write a
story about killing Peter Parker huh huh
well Baldr men than you have tried and
failed my friend we all know this isn't
permanent especially in a story about
time travel so let's think logically
about how we could do this well he needs
to die defending his moral code that he
never shuts up about so we got to have
him stopping a threat from endangering
lives
O'Hara if you don't get that I can't
turn my back on danger no matter what
the cost then you got no business
calling yourself spider-man Oh NAB check
we need him to get killed by his best
villain and who is spider-man's nemesis
that's right ladies stilt man
just kidding his venom but oh no venom
is no longer venom in the comics he
hasn't been for three years Eddie Brock
lost the suit and Scorpion took it so he
could be a total jobber and get his ass
kicked all the time but Eddie Brock has
a better connection with spider-man well
he makes spider-man's powers go away by
touching him and he's current in the
comic world as of 2011 all right
anti-venom it is even though he's not as
cool and everything about him makes no
sense okay so the villain of the first
half of the game walker sloan mine
controls venom to be his bodyguard and
help him uh do something why is that I'm
here to bomb the place what there are
multiple boss fights with anti-venom and
each one gets more difficult than the
last as it starts you beat him pretty
easily but he keeps pulling out more
tricks as it continues first he starts
self-healing then he takes away your
ability to dodge by the end of it you
feel so helpless and all you can do is
crawl away while it gets closer and
closer which is pretty unnerving
eventually Miguel swoops in to save the
day
Peter tags out with his Daft Punk buddy
and we begin round two this piece of the
boss fight is great because it really
shows the differences in the two main
characters 2099 can't have his powers
drained and is twice as strong so he
starts knocking ven around like a hank
pym love interest
venom comes back to his senses after a
thorough beating thus he knocks the evil
businessman and Doc Ock who is just
there for some reason into the portal to
die in agony for all eternity in the
time between atto seconds smash cut back
to the future and Peter is all healed
and stuck in 2099 while Miguel is in the
past being the only character who knows
what the hell is going on the portal is
broken and they spend the next few hours
of gameplay just trying to keep the
situation settled while things are slow
I'll talk about the gameplay for a
second this game is indeed just an
extension of shattered Dimensions but
there is one new feature both spider-man
have a unique dodge ability miguel can
move so quickly that decoy of himself is
still present that the enemies will
shoot at while he sneaks up behind them
peter can move like me oh and never get
hit in this mode these are both neat
little powers that makes no sense in
realistic terms but serve as cool
gameplay mechanics the free-falling that
2099 can do is still here but much more
refined there are some of the coolest
sequences in the game and I find myself
constantly wondering when the next one
will be because they're so fun it's
great trying to make it through one of
them using the speed boost the whole
time so you're going as fast as possible
and try not to hit anything another
unique thing is the time travel stuff
factoring into the gameplay where a
thing going on in the past is
inconveniencing a spider-man in future
so you have to change the past to save
the future basically you have to delete
some architects files so in 83 years
they won't have a room with walls that
close in and shoot flames I feel like
some random employee at Alka Mex is
having the worst day ever trying to find
his files for the company death chamber
may be his manager Karen starts yelling
at him for his incompetence
sometimes time just gets all
wibbly-wobbly and walls just appear or
disappear out of nowhere it's nuts what
other weird stuff are we going to see
well we get to the most annoying boss
fight in the game black cat is here or a
bunch of clones of her at least fighting
her is a pain in the ass this boss fight
is broken it's the worst one in the
entire series of spider-man games all
the way back to 2001 she can just block
90% of your punches and you have to
constantly worry about dodging the other
15 clones that are beating on you too
and in typical fashion you have to chase
her somewhere while you fight and her
dialogue is nothing but sexual innuendos
now would she go you're getting warmer
spider come find me
you know I'm gonna make you work for it
be honest was I yeah good
you're great better than the original
man the future is wacky I hate it here
so back to the story
well Peter is stuck in the future and
finds out that the CEO of alchemax in
this crazy timeline is him oh my god
well this is an interesting villain so
evil Peter from the future wants to use
the power of time being broken to make
himself a god that way he can fix all of
his numerous screw-ups in life and
create a perfect world when the storm is
fully Unleashed I'm going to harness the
quantum energy it will give me complete
control over the times complete what are
you trying to play God I can make up for
my original sin by saving Uncle Ben not
to mention when Stacy her dad countless
others what kind of villain fixes it so
that everyone gets to live happily ever
after that's actually not a bad goal I
mean abusing power is wrong and also we
should probably intervene but I want to
go on record as saying I'm not a hundred
percent on board for it actually maybe
evil future Peter is not the most stable
guy
I even as the company CEO he's not the
best person to be in charge I don't
think mr. Parker has the authorization
to create a harem of sex clones I'm
going to have to bring this up at the
next board meeting uh yes he's misusing
company resources for a comically large
Botanical Garden and a group of
genetically engineered copies of his
dead ex-girlfriend is that is that just
fine with everyone oh okay all right who
needs an office this big is he playing
racquetball on here when no one's
looking so all three of the people who
fell under the poor will get mushed
together into a monster that can control
time and wants nothing more than the
murder spider-man which happens all the
time even though this is clearly those
three guys it takes a goddamn blood test
to figure it out for these two dunces
who are both apparently scientists
somehow but this creature is called
atrocity and is probably my favorite
boss fight of any spider-man game ever
which I know is surprising it isn't even
a thing from the comics I like that it's
almost a guaranteed death of this thing
gets close to you because of how
freakishly powerful it is it isn't
really even much of a boss fight it's
just a chase that never lets up you can
hear it screaming behind the walls
everywhere and you never know when it's
just going to show up and eat you when
spider idiot has to get the blood sample
he lures it into a room where you have
to keep goading it into this chamber
with knockout gas and each time it wakes
up it uses more weird time powers this
is really cool and original oh just
another day in the life what's up
yeah
uh wait a minute they did this exact
premise for a monster 11 years ago I
still like it better here and the semi
reference is pretty cool
this means we have two main villains a
weird monster that's ripping apart time
with its very existence and evil
spider-man who wants to use that power
to reshape the universe the climax of
this game is a kick-ass battle in two
eras of time where each spider-man uses
the help of the other to beat their own
final boss
if I had to list my favorite thing about
this game it's the pacing the entire
game has this feeling of being in a
hurry and getting repeatedly stopped up
before getting to whatever it is you
need to do it's like you just always
feel like you're running out of time
which is perfect considering the subject
matter
everything has a timer built into it and
you always feel out of breath the pacing
is fantastic and it's great hearing the
back-and-forth between these two
characters at the beginning of the
adventure they really don't like each
other but they become friends after
saving each other so many times and
basically reshaping the whole universe
the gameplay is more of the same if you
enjoyed shattered Dimensions and this
one has some continuity ties to that one
too I I coulda I could talk for hours
about how this Easter Egg ruins the
entire plot but it's fine spider-man
2099 is one of my favorite characters
and I'm so happy to see that he got not
one but two games to show how awesome
that premises these games are what
caused the minor resurgence in his
popularity and have revived his long
since cancelled comic series so this
video game had a bit of a butterfly
effect on the comic world people should
really go out and read that stuff by the
way it's great so we're finally done
talking about the second multiversal
crossover these games come in twos I
guess next up we have a movie tie-in
game attached to a movie series that no
longer exists starring a voice cast
trying super hard to make up for the
fact that the movie cast isn't here oh
joy
good try spider-man but I've had a
hundred years to plan this keep your
friends close and your enemies closer I
kept you close to keep an eye on you
make use [ __ ] you just shut the [ __ ] up